Okay, good morning class. Um, so we have
five more classes in the semester and
the four last classes are the most
important.
So what what I will do this class is set
up the uh background and context for the
last four classes. So um what I want to
do first is review what what we've
learned so far. Okay, so we discussed
the um Roman Republic.
the Roman Republic
and it was essentially an oligarchy.
Okay, so oligarchy just means rule by
the few. So it's very much like Sparta.
It is a war society.
And at this point in history,
the fact that the Roman Republic was an
oligarchy, basically it had about 100
families that commanded it. Okay? And
these were called the Petricians.
It was actually to the advantage of um
Rome because at this time Rome was small
um it was poor. It was at war. Okay. So
in other words,
even though there was nobility, they
were not that much better off than other
people and everyone knew each other. So
they were very um open, energetic and
cohesive society. And so over time they
became the most dominant society in the
Mediterranean. They defeated um
Carthage, they defeated the Greeks. But
now that they're an empire,
the fact that Rome is an oligarchy is a
huge problem because now they are
corrupt,
um unequal
and stagnant. And one way that we know
is
um Roman women just start to refuse to
have children. Okay, so they were dying
as a society.
And at this point in history, what
should happen is that they should build
an imperial bureaucracy,
a centralized centralized
um system in order to better manage the
empire. Well, they couldn't really do
that because the oligarchy, the
families, which now are about 50, okay?
They refused to give up power. So rather
than a centralized
um bureaucracy, the Roman Empire was in
many ways
um a system in which different families
have different territories. And what
this led to was constant civil war.
Okay, civil war.
And remember um it started with Sula and
then it went on to Julius Caesar and
after Julius Caesar August of Caesar
became the first among equals but he
still failed to set up the bureaucracy.
Okay. And so it kept on leading to war.
Eventually what happened was that
Constantine decided this system doesn't
work. So what what I need to do is I
need to reinvent the Roman people. And
you do that by moving the capital from
Rome to a new place he calls Conanopole.
Okay? Which now becomes the Basantine
Empire.
Okay? And the Russian Empire
now because it's a new culture, it can
now become a bureaucracy. In fact, their
official language becomes Greek. It's a
Greek bureaucracy.
Okay? And this this is what we call the
second Rome.
At the same time, while this is
happening, you have a massive migration
of the steps people. Okay, they're
coming into Europe from many different
locations. Why is this happening?
Because in China, the Han dynasty is
waging a war against the steps demonatic
people. Okay, the people who call the
Shongu
then so they're forced westwards which
forces the other steps people to migrate
into Europe and into Central Asia.
Okay. So these people are called the
Goffs
and this is a huge problem for Rome
because their people are not having
children and they have all these massive
migration coming in from the steps.
And so what the Romans decided to do is
divide and rule. And so what this means
is that a lot of them are absorbed into
the army as mercenaries and as soldiers
in order to defend the border in order
to fight these civil wars.
Now remember last class we talked about
the rise of the Catholic Church. Okay.
And we discussed how the Catholic Church
was in many ways being supported by
these noble families. Not all of them
supported the Catholic Church, but some
of them did. And those that did had a
huge advantage because now what they can
do is absorb
these new migrants into the society
where they're at the top and the uh
migrants are at the bottom. Okay. Then
the question then is why would the
migrants agree to this? The reason why
is in the society it is very
egalitarian.
And for war purposes they would they
would elect a war leader. Okay.
But with this system with the Catholic
church system there this war leader can
now become a nobility.
Okay. They can now join the 50 families
to form a new nobility.
Okay. Does that make sense guys? All
right. All right. So at this point in
history when Constantine sets up the
Bison Empire now the Roman Empire is
going to divide into two a western part
a western part [snorts]
and an eastern part.
And these two parts are going to have
very different fates. The eastern part
is still part of the Middle East. Okay,
the Lavant, Anatolia, Egypt and so it is
the wealthiest part of
um the empire and as such it engages in
wars with the um Persian Empire. Okay.
And this will define most of its
history. Its capital Consenopol was
designed to be invincible. You could not
lay siege to it. You could not conquer
it. And as such, the Bison Empire was
stable. In fact, it lasted for about a
thousand years, which is very very
impressive. Okay. And as I said, it's
very wealthy. And so therefore it's
really able to dominate
um
the world through
mainly trade and diplomacy.
Okay. So it became an imperial
bureaucracy. It fought wars but it
usually used a lot of mercenaries
because it had a lot of wealth.
All right. So that's the Eastern Empire.
And guess what guys? This is very
similar to China. Okay. So, think about
China. When you think about the Bison
Empire, they're not the same, but
they're very similar in how they
organize the society. The Western Empire
is very different because it's the
poorest part of Europe. The other thing
about this region is that there are lots
of natural barriers.
[snorts]
And so, you have like these competing
societies
emerging,
okay? different cultures, different
societies, and they're protected by
mountains, by forests, by rivers. So,
there's a lot of diversity. There's a
lot of diversity within the western
uh empire. And so, the power that
emerges is actually the Catholic Church.
And as
Western Europe increases in power and
Eastern Europe uh in decreases in power,
the Catholic Church will increase in
power as well. Okay. How the Catholic
Church come dominate Western Europe?
Because the west because Catholic Church
believes it is out of history.
Okay. So you kings, you compete for who
rules the earth. But we, the Catholic
Church, we decide who goes to heaven.
Okay? So the Catholic Church becomes the
dominant power in Western Europe. In
fact, you can say that they are the
empire now. But they are a spiritual
empire,
a divine empire that is out of history
and which speaks for God. And as such
they become a very powerful
empire as well. Okay. And this leads to
tremendous conflicts throughout Western
Europe. Okay. But there's a problem with
the Catholic church and we discussed
this last class with the Catholic
Church.
It's trying to control the divine spark.
Remember Jesus came to tell us that
there's a divine spark in us. And as
long as we try to glow this divine
spark, we can be with God. And the c the
Catholic Church says, "No, no, no. This
divine spark, it is that of the devil
and we must imprison it." Okay? And this
works most of the time. But now and then
you have religious leaders who arise and
said, "No, no, no. The divine spark is
within us." And so this leads to a lot
of conflict. And ultimately the solution
the Catholic Church proposes is the idea
of crusades
where warriors go and
um kill those who believe in the divine
spark. And then they set up a secret
police called the acquisition
in order to
search for those who oppose the Catholic
Church. Okay. the inquisition. Um the
the the major idea is
if you believe in the divine spark,
you're not an evil person, you're a
stupid person because you don't know
better. So the idea of acquisition is to
educate you in the truth which is divine
spark is that of Satan, that of the
devil and therefore you must obey the
Catholic Church. But if you insist
on defying the Catholic Church, then you
are a heretic and therefore you must
burn at the stake before you can pollute
other people. Okay? Now eventually what
will happen is that as a conflict in
Western Europe gets worse and worse
certain states will break away from the
control of the Catholic Church and they
will embrace a new religion called
Protest Protestantism. Okay.
And this something we'll discuss next
class.
Okay. So that's a history of Western
Europe. Okay. So now I want to talk
about Constantine and the rise of the
Bentim Empire. So Constantine
is what he does that's very important is
that he makes Christianity the official
religion of Rome. So before Constantine
you had Christian emperors but they did
not make Christian the official religion
but he made Christian the official
religion. Okay. The problem though we
discussed this last class is that
Christian it's a franchise model. So
different churches teach different
things
and so Constantine was like no we can't
have this debate if we if we'll make
this the official religion what we need
to do is
have one orthodoxy
a unified ideology. Okay. All right. So
at this time in history there are two
major debates or two major source source
of confusion. The first is what we call
christologology.
What this is is the question of like
what's the nature
of Jesus. Okay remember the story is
that Jesus is in heaven then he comes to
earth. Mary gives birth to Jesus. Then
Jesus
preaches his message, the gospel.
Then he is killed and he is resurrected
and then he returns to heaven. Okay,
that's the official story of
Christianity. But there are lots of
problems with the story as you can
imagine. If Jesus is the vine, how did
Mary give birth to Jesus? Right? If
you're a human woman and you give birth
to a god, that means that you're God
yourself. Okay? Right? So, who is Mary
and what is her power? Second question
then is, is Jesus divine or is he human?
Okay? Because if he's human, he dies.
That's a sacrifice, right? But if you're
divine, you can't die. So, his death and
his resurrection doesn't make any sense.
Okay. So, so this is a problem
Christologology. Is Jesus human or is he
divine? And there are different
interpretations. Okay. The first
interpretation is Jesus is divine in
heaven, but he's human in the world.
Okay, does that make sense? So, yes,
Mary gave birth to Jesus, but she gave
birth to the human Jesus and not the
divine Jesus because you cannot give
birth to divine God. Okay? And that's
why his death makes sense because the
because the Jesus who died was the human
Jesus but once he died and he was
resurrected then he went to heaven.
Okay, that's that's one explanation that
Jesus is really human. Another
explanation is no Jesus is divine. So
Mary the death doesn't really matter.
Okay, he's just divine. Okay, so both
are possibilities.
What the church says officially is Jesus
is human and divine at the same time.
Okay, this is the official
ideology of the church. This makes no
sense, guys. All right, but that's what
um you're taught. And so there are a lot
of course people who are like this is a
stupid idea. Okay. And these people are
called the Neestorans.
And they were persecuted by the Catholic
Church. And so they went to Persia.
Okay? They went to the Middle East. They
went to Persia. They went to Arabia
where they spread the message of Jesus.
They taught Jesus as a human as opposed
to a God. They taught that Jesus was a
messenger. Okay? Which is what I taught
you, right? that he's really a messenger
of the monad.
All right. So, does that make sense?
Okay. Now, now the second debate is
actually more confusing than the first
debate. Okay. And it has to do with the
nature of the three powerful forces,
right? The three gods. You have God, the
ultimate God, and you have Jesus and you
have the Holy Spirit. The Holy Spirit is
God expressed in the world. Okay? So,
when you have a when someone speaks to
you, you think it's God. It's actually
not God. It's the Holy Spirit. All
right. So now the question is what's the
relationship between these three God,
Jesus and Holy Spirit? And again there
are different explanations and they kind
of make sense. Okay. So the first is the
idea of modalism.
Modalism is the is the idea that Jesus
and God and Holy Spirit are just
different modes of the same thing. They
just change. So when Jesus is is in
heaven, he's God. When Jesus comes to
earth as a human, he's just Jesus. And
then when Jesus wants to communicate
with us, he's the Holy Spirit. Okay? So
remember, but Paul talked to Jesus, but
Paul didn't really talk to Jesus. Paul
talked to the Holy Spirit. Okay? So it's
the same force but expressed
differently. Okay, that makes sense,
right? Second is the idea of partialism.
Partialism is just the idea that
God, Jesus, the Holy Spirit all part of
the same divine force. Okay? something
of an ocean, right? The Pacific Ocean.
The Pacific Ocean is huge, but there are
different parts to it, right? So that's
the idea of partial that makes sense
too, right? Okay. The third idea is the
idea of Arinism. Aryanism [snorts]
and Aryanism is just the idea that God
came first
and therefore and then afterwards he
created Jesus. So in other words, Jesus
is God, but he's second to the real God.
Okay, that makes sense as well, right?
Now, there are problems with all three.
Okay,
the first problem
is if you read the Bible, Jesus talks to
God. Jesus talks to the Holy Spirit.
That's kind of confusing because why
would Jesus talk to himself? Okay, so
there's a lot of inconsistencies
in the Bible. Okay, so this doesn't
really work.
Partialism doesn't work either because
if you think about it, if God, Jesus,
and Holy Spirit are part of a divine
aspect, then that divine aspect should
be God, right? Not these three. Okay,
that doesn't this doesn't really make
sense. And arenism doesn't really make
sense because the entire point of
Christianity is to say that Jesus is
God, right? We worship Jesus, not God.
So if you're saying that God's superior,
why shouldn't we worship God instead of
Jesus? Okay. So this is problemat
problematic as well. So what Constantine
did was he organized all the bishops of
the different churches to come to Nikia.
It's called the council of Nikia.
Okay. In order to
come up with a solution to this problem.
And their solution is actually even more
problematic than these three. Okay? And
it's called the Holy Trinity. So, let's
go over the Holy Trinity.
What the Holy Trinity says is this.
God,
Jesus,
and the Holy Spirit,
they are separate. Okay?
But they are equal.
They are separate, but they're part of
the same thing. Okay? They're both
separate and they are
equal to each other. Okay? Now, if you
think about it, it makes actually no
sense whatsoever. The only solution this
problem is that
this holy trinity is both nothing and
everything at the same time. It becomes
reality on to itself.
Okay.
And the only way to understand this is
to accept this as a reality.
All right? So I know there's confusion
confusion but think of the idea of
money. Right?
Okay. So the idea of money is both
nothing and everything. Okay? Money is
nothing but it can be everything at the
same time as well because it symbolizes
wealth. Okay? Does that make sense?
Right? So none of this actually makes
any sense. And the only way that it
makes sense is if you force it to make
sense. If you just memorize it. So think
of math class. Okay guys, I'm not sure
if you appreciate this, but the entire
point of math class is to make you
stupid. Okay? Why? Because it is
impossible for you to reason
using mathematics. Because mathematics
doesn't really apply to the world. So
only thing that you can do is just
memorize the formulas and apply the
formulas to each other. Okay? And that
just requires massive memorization and
regurgitation. That's why if you think
about it, the best ma ma mathematicians
are always in their 20s or 30s because
you because your brain has to be like
really energetic in order to process
this information. But the older you get,
the less capable you are in mathematics.
Okay? Does it make sense? This is really
important guys. The more math you learn,
the stupid you become. Okay? But this
goes against say um philosophy or
teaching, right? The older you get, the
worse you become. Why? Because the
information that you're learning, you
can apply to reality and then figure out
what information makes sense as you as
you test this information against
reality. Okay.
All right. Okay. So then the question
then is
why would they do this?
And the answer is very simple. To make
you stupid. Okay. So, so let's let let's
just use a an analogy. Let's do a
thought experiment. The sky is blue,
right? So, we know the sky is blue. And
now we're like, okay, why is the sky
blue? And is it always blue? And why are
certain things blue? Okay, from this I
from this verb principle, the sky is
blue. You can now start to ask more
questions. You can based on this idea
start to reason out more things. Okay,
does that make sense? But let's just say
I change. I say the sky is red.
You're like, "No, the sky is blue." I'm
say, "No, no, the sky is red." If you do
not say the sky is red, you are a
heretic. I will burn you at the steak.
You're like, "Okay, all right. So, what
you're saying is this. You're saying
that blue is red. Red is blue." And I'm
and I'm like, "No, no, no. Blue is blue.
Red is red. the sky is is red and you're
like that makes no sense and it's like
okay well then I don't care because if
you do not say the sky is red I will
burn you to sick okay I will fail you in
school okay you understand so another
way of saying this is your brain
uh the way it process information is by
using logic right okay so think think
about building
think about building
Okay, think of a building. Okay, well,
this makes sense, right? You're just
stacking build like blocks on top of
each other to build a building, right?
But let's just say I make you I say,
"No, no, this is what the building looks
like. Okay, this is empty." You're like,
"Well, that makes no sense."
Okay. So, what I've done by forcing the
idea of the holy trinity onto you is
I've basically taken a part of your
logical system of of your brain and
emptied it out. So, it's impossible for
you to connect things. Okay? Because
from this, what you can do is say, well,
now I can just keep on building more
things, right?
But if the principle is there's a layer
that's that is unseen or unobable, you
can't build on top of it. Okay. So your
brain ceases to be able to process and
be creative. Okay. Does that make sense?
Yeah.
And I saw like people who learn math
well and also like they have strong
ability in computer science. They all
like work in Silicon Valley and they are
wealthy. But I think that also aligns
our concept that they are pursuing the
materialistic and they are you know the
world is ruled by Satan. Is that true?
>> Yeah. Okay. Um we'll talk about this
later. Okay. But but yeah, if you work
in Silicon Valley, uh you are a
materialistic person who is incapable of
of thinking spiritually. Yes, that that
is correct. Also like also remember like
people who do computer computer
engineering and do mathematics
like they're at the best in their 20s
and 30s by the time they reach over 40
they kind of burn out. Okay? Because you
know for for your brain to process all
this um eventually burns out. Okay? Does
that make sense? So again, I hate to say
this, but math makes you stupid. All
right.
All right. Um, is is that clear, guys?
Any questions? Okay. But as you can see,
what's happening is that because people
are forced to learn this, they don't
want to learn this. And this starts a
series of wars within the Roman Empire
because Constantine and the Bison Empire
is going to enforce this orthodoxy onto
every Christian church and it starts a
series of wars. Okay. At the same time
the Bisantines
they are fighting the Sassin Persia.
Assassin Persia. Okay. Egypt,
the Levant,
and this is Arabia.
Okay, so guys, this is really important.
This is a time in history, this this
about 500 to 600 where there's a lot of
conflict going on. Okay, remember the
first major conflict is between
Bisantine and Sassin Persians. Okay. The
second major conflict is the church
orthodoxy against
um the independent church franchises.
Okay. So the B empire is trying to
enforce the orthodoxy on all
different churches who refuse to who
refuse the Holy Trinity because it's
such a silly idea. Okay. What this is
going to do is it's going to force
Christians
over
to the Sassin as well as Arabia, the
desert. Okay? And these these are called
Nestorians. Now, and again, they believe
that Jesus is a divine messenger as
opposed to
um God on earth. Okay?
Also, we have the Jews as well. Okay?
because the Jews keep on resisting
against the Romans because the the
Romans forced the Jews to obey
Christianity and so the Jews escape into
Arabia.
Okay. And at the same time the Jews want
to return to Jerusalem.
Right now, what's interesting is that
most people don't know this, but Arabia
is at this point in history the most
energetic, open, and cohesive society
um in the Middle East. Okay. So, first
of all, it's open because Arabia has
always been a point of trade between uh
the Levant Egypt and uh the inner valley
civilization. Okay. India.
Okay. So Arabia they uh do a lot of
trading but they also uh great are great
fighters because they're great
mercenaries. Why?
Because as the Sassin and the Romans
fight more and more the Arabians are
recruited in as mercenaries for their
armies and as such they learn the most
innovative warfare and they're poor as
well. So they're really good fighters.
Okay. And now what's happening is that
the Arabians, the Arabs are be are are
being exposed to new religions, the
netoring Christianity as well as
Judaism. Okay. And both preach the
coming of the Messiah.
Okay. So Arabia is rising in energy but
the bison empire
and the assassinated Persians are
decreasing in energy. Okay. The bison
are fighting too many wars and they're
imposing too much orthodoxy which is
turning people into slaves. And because
the sass are fighting the the
bisonantines in war and as the bison
become more orthodox and become more
bureaucratic the sass are forced to
become much more bureaucratic as well.
Much more orthodox as well. And so the
Neestorans are also being persecuted by
the Sass the Sassin. So the Jews want
Jerusalem to return and assassin says to
the Jews, "Hey, if you fight for us,
we'll return Jerusalem to you." Okay?
And so the Bisantines, so the Jews went
back to Jerusalem and that piss off the
Bisantine. So they come and they kill a
lot of Jews. Now the thing about the
Jewish tradition is they believe that
when they're most persecuted, when all
hope is lost, their Messiah will come to
save them. Okay? So the Jews are like,
"Oh my god, the Messiah is coming. The
Messiah is coming." Okay. The historians
also believe the Messiah is coming as
well. They believe that Jesus is going
to return. And all it will take is for
one charismatic leader to emerge
in the Arabian desert to say, "I'm
Messiah. Follow me. What I will promise
you is this. I promise you that you will
have the right to believe in whatever
religion you want because the divine
spark is in you
and you know how to best celebrate God
by yourself. I promise religious
tolerance for the Jews, for the
Christians, for the Arabs, for everyone.
Okay? And so what will happen is this
leader will emerge and his name is
Muhammad.
And Muhammad will unite Arabia and then
he will unite the Netorians. He will
unite the Jews and they will together
fight to get Jerusalem back. They will
fight to get to against Persia. And
guess what happens?
They basically win without much
resistance because there's so much
anger, so much opposition towards the
Sassin Empire as well as the Bison
Empire. Plus, both empires are
exhausted. And so this gives us the
Islamic revolution, right? Okay.
The Arabs are able to sweep through and
conquer most of the world very very
quickly. But when they do so, what
happens is that Muhammad dies. And now
what's going to happen is they have lots
of different factions, right? The
Nisorans, the Jews, the Arabs as well.
And they're going to fight a civil war
amongst themselves as well. And then
from the civil war will emerge a new
religion that we call Islam.
Okay, but remember this is really
important.
Mohamad himself did not preach Islam.
All he preached was I'm Messiah. I'm the
messenger of God like Jesus and I
will promote religious tolerance. We'll
have a community of believers and
followers in Jesus. But it doesn't
matter if you're Jew. It doesn't matter
if you're Christian. It doesn't matter
what type Christianity you are. You're
free to believe whatever you want
because that's what God wants.
>> I think it work on the although like
Muhammad said that you have the right to
believe in your divine spark but I think
they all walk on the same road as Paul
because they all formed an religion
because they follow Muhammad but not
follow themselves.
>> Okay. So this is really important idea
you guys need to understand the
messenger of God. Okay, the leader the
messiah
he's never like I'm God follow me. He's
always like, "I'm a messenger of God."
And the me message of God is, "You are
divine children." That's divine spark is
in you. You should not be slaves. I will
free you from slavery. I will free you
from tyranny. I will free you from
poverty. Okay? That's always the
messenger. That that's always the
message. What will happen later on after
some time is you have a figure like
polymer emerge who needs I can turn this
into my own empire and then organiz
religion becomes organized okay that's
always the process so think of zor thusa
when he first came he was preaching a
message he was he was a poet prophet so
was Jesus so is homer so was Muhammad
but later on
people will turn his words into to an
empire. Okay, that's always the process.
All right. Okay. Clear. All right.
Okay.
So, let's do the PPT.
So, so, so we can um better understand
what happened. Okay. So as we discussed
before
at this point at this point in history
the Roman Empire it's huge but please
remember that it's on a bureaucracy and
therefore each re region is controlled
by a certain noble family okay the
patricians
and as a result what happened is as
okay and and these are like the 50 top
families in Rome and there there aren't
that many Okay. And then what will
happen is there are certain families
that will adapt well to the change in
the Roman Empire mainly by
by embracing ca Catholic religion. Okay.
By being early investors in the Catholic
Church and as such they will continue on
to today. We call these people the black
nobility. Okay.
All right. So as I mentioned the there
are different migrants coming in from
the steps. The Huns, the Germanics, the
Slavs, they're basically all the steps
people. Okay, but they will come into
different regions and they will absorb
and they will absorb into Europe
differently. Okay, in the north they're
much more independent and this is where
the Vikings are. Okay, these are where
the Germans are. They're very
independent independent people. But as
they approach the Roman Empire, they are
assimilated and absorbed by the Roman
nobility using the Catholic religion.
Okay? And so the people at the very
bottom here, they become uh Christians.
Okay? But they become different types of
Christians and eventually they'll fight
fight the Bisantines because the
Bisonines want to enforce an Orthodox
Christianity onto them.
Okay? And uh this is what Europe looks
like when the Western Empire falls.
Okay, as you can see, there are
different societies as well. And again,
what makes this possible is the fact
that Western Europe, it has a lot of
mountains. So it's pretty easy to defend
your territory.
Okay, so this is Constantine and he is
going to make Christianity the official
religion of the Roman Empire when he
becomes emperor. Okay. So, so again even
even though even even after Julius
Caesar the Romans cannot stop cannot
help but keep on fighting civil wars and
Constantine wins one of them becomes
emperor and he moves the capital from
Rome all the way to Constantinople.
Okay, this is really important because
now he can establish a new culture
called the Bisantine Empire. Okay, they
call themselves Romans but they're not
really Romans and more like Greeks.
Another major difference is this. Rome
is over in Western Europe. Consenapole
is off in Eastern Europe. And so now
it's and now Rome is now able to defend
its wealthy provinces of Anatolia and
Egypt much more effectively. Okay. The
other thing about Kipole that's really
important is it's pretty easy to defend.
Okay? Because it's by the sea and if you
build high walls, it's almost impossible
for people to invade uh Kanole. This is
the Hag Sophia which is the official
church of the new religion. Okay. Today
we call it Eastern Orthodox
but back then it was just the Catholic
church. Okay. And this is the Haga
Sophia.
Um this is what Kimple looks like at its
peak. And what's really important to
understand is it's very wealthy but as
you can see it's surrounded by these
seaw walls which makes it impossible to
defend. And that's why it was able to
stand for about a thousand years.
Okay. Uh the council nikia is where they
make the holy trinity the official
doctrine of the Catholic church. Even
today, guys, if you're a Christian, you
still recite it. All right. It's called
the Nasin Creed. So, can can you read
it? Um Alec,
we believe in one God, the Father
Almighty, maker of heaven and earth, and
of all things visible and invisible. And
in one Lord Jesus Christ, the Son of
God, the only begotten, begotten of the
Father before all ages, light of light,
true God of true God, forgotten not
made, of one essence with the Father, by
whom all things were made, whom for us
men and for all salvation, come down
from heaven, and was inc incarnate of
the Holy Spirit and the Virgin Mary, and
became man, and he was crucified for us
under Pontius
Pate. died and suffered and was buried.
And the third day he rose again
according to the scriptures and ascended
into heaven and sits at the right hand
of the father and he shall come again
with glory to judge the living and the
dead whose kingdom shall have no end and
in the holy spirit.
>> Right? So this what this does is
establish the idea that Jesus, God, holy
spirit are separate but they are one and
the same. They are different but they
are co-equal. Right? If you actually
study this next scene creed, you'll find
a lot of inconsistencies. Okay? So Jesus
Christ is a son of God, but um he is um
one with God as well. Okay? So if you
think about it, um it doesn't really
make much sense. Okay? But again, the
nin creed is something that you don't
argue over because you argue over it,
you're a heretic. You'll be burned at
the stake. is something that you just
you must memorize. It's like a math
formula basically. Okay. In in math
class, you're not allowed to question a
formula. You're just forced to memorize
the formula. Okay.
[clears throat]
Okay. So, as you can see, what's
happening is that the migrants are being
settled throughout Europe. Okay.
But uh but but once they're being
settled through Europe, the conflict
between these noble families in in in
Rome then become a conflict amongst
these different groups. Okay.
All right. So after the council of Nikia
announced the holy trinity, there's
still a lot of resistance to it. In
fact, you know, even by the year 500,
which which is about 180 years after the
council of Nikia, most of Europe is
actually they don't really believe in
the Holy Trinity. Okay? So, Iran just
means you don't believe in the Holy
Trinity. Catholic means you do. And as
you can see, this part which is
controlled by the Bison Empire, it's it
is it's able to enforce the Holy
Trinity, but most other parts are not
able to enforce the Holy Trinity. Okay,
this is really important idea to
understand. The idea of the Holy Trinity
only takes force a few hundred years
after it is announced. But in the
beginning, there's a lot of resistance
to the idea of the Holy Trinity. The Ban
Empire must fight these wars to enforce
it. Okay? And it will because as Banan
Empire becomes stronger and stronger,
you can see these [clears throat] green
arrows. It's going to fight all these
wars in order to expand the idea of the
Holy Trinity. Okay? And Kasambo can do
this because it's very wealthy and it
doesn't really fear any enemies because
of high walls. Okay.
Okay. As you can see, it's almost
impossible to attack Constanible from by
sea.
All right. And the Bing Empire under
Justinian will
expand and expand and enforce the Holy
Trinity on all churches. Okay. And by
565 it is at the peak of its power.
But as we discussed when the empire
become reaches its peak it's usually
it's probably going to fall really
quickly and that's what happens.
All right. So because of resistance holy
trinity Christians are forced into the
Persian Empire and into the Arabian
desert. Okay. At first they're welcome
by the Persians because these tend to be
very well educated Christians who
contribute a lot to the empire. [music]
But over time uh the Zoroastrians see
the Christians as a threat and conflict
arises between Christians and the
Zoroastrians.
The Christians will also go into the uh
Arabian desert as well to promote
Christianity. Okay. As you can see how
many how Christianity spreads the story
in Christianity also spreads to China
and Japan. Okay.
All right. Um one thing that you need to
understand is that even though we don't
we don't really discuss Arabia a lot,
it's a very important part of the world
throughout of history because it's a
trade center. Okay. So if you're India
and you want to bring goods into Egypt,
the best thing to do is to uh sell into
Muscat and then uh have Arabian nomads
carry the goods all the way to Mecca and
then go into Egypt. Okay. So the Arabian
desert, we don't talk much about it, but
it is a crossroads of empire and it's a
crossroads of culture as well. And there
are Jews in the Arabian desert because
um as the Romans persecute the Jews, the
the Jews go escape into Arabia because
the
um Romans don't like sand. Okay, the
Romans what they're really good at is
besieging cities, but they hate fighting
sand. That's why the Romans cannot can
never conquer Persia.
All right. So, uh this is another map
that shows the extent of the trade as
well. Okay.
Um so, as you can see the Arabian
desert, it's connecting the world,
right? Because like you look at India
and and India is now able to connect the
world through the Arabian desert. Okay?
Okay. It backs as Europe, the
Mediterranean and Egypt through the
Arabian desert. Okay. [snorts]
Okay. So, what's going to happen is that
once Muhammad comes into place and he
unites the Arabian desert into a new
community of followers, okay, they they
will spread really quickly throughout
the world. And as you can see,
there are now um over a billion Muslims
in the world. And you can see how many
Muslims there are in the world. Okay.
Um so there's a lot of conflict between
the Roman Empire, the Bisantines and the
Assassin as well. Okay. There are lots
of lots of major battles. These wars are
exhausting both empires. And this is
this is going to enable the Arabs to um
rise in power because as these two
empires fight and their energy
decreases, this energy is being
transferred to to the Arabs. Okay?
Because a lot of wealth is being
transferred to the Arabs. But also a lot
of mercenaries are learning how to fight
uh from the Bantine from the Bison as
well as the Persians. Okay.
All right. So um the major event that
sparks the uh Arab revolution is the
persecution of the Jews. Okay. So um
Alan, can you read please?
>> The Persian army reinforced by Jewish
force led by Nihama Ben Hasher and
Benjamin of Turbaris would capture
Jerusalem without resistance.
>> Okay. So the Jews want to return to
Jerusalem. Remember the Romans kicked
the Jews out of Jerusalem. So they make
a deal with the Persians, okay? They
basically say to the Persians, if you
support us, we'll support you in the
fight against the Romans. And that's
what happened. But once that happens,
there are lots of Christians within
Jerusalem and they call the Bisantines
for help.
And
um so the Bisonines come and they take
they went back to the city because the
Christians help them. and they start
masking masking a lot of Jews. Okay.
>> The capture of Jerusalem was interpreted
by Jewish writer in the Masonic context.
Sacrifices may even have been renewed on
the temple mount. Control of the city
was handled to Nihama Ben Hashiel and
Benjaming of Turbus. Nahama was then
appointed the ruler of Jerus Jerus
Jerusalem. She began making arrangement
for the building of the third temple and
sorting out genealologies of established
new high priesthood.
>> Okay. So this is almost the Bible where
the Jews were kicked out of Jerusalem by
the Babylonians
um and the temple was burned down. And
so what so what the Jews believe is like
now the new Messiah will return. We have
to rebuild the third temple because in
their religion the Messiah will return
all Jews to Jerusalem and build the
third temple. Okay.
>> All right. Keep on going.
>> Yeah. After only a few months, a
Christian revolt occurred. Nahama Ben
Hash and his council of 16 righteous
were killed along with many other Jews.
Some throwing themselves off the city
walls. Following the outburst of
violence in Jerus Jerusalem, the
surviving Jews fled to Shambara's
encampment encampment at
>> Cesyia.
>> Ciceria Christians were able to briefly
retake the city before the walls were
breached by Sahabas forces who lay siege
to the city. Sources vary on how long
the siege lasted. Depending on the
source, it lasted 19, 20 or 21 days.
>> Okay. Right. So the Jews take reach take
over Jerusalem and they want to build
rebuild their temple and the Christians
are angry because they think this is my
city. The Christians rebel and the
Protestants help them and the Jews are
massacred and a lot and a lot escape.
Where they go? They go to the Arabian
desert. Why do they go to the Arabian
desert? Because they they believe the
Messiah is going to come. And so they
preach that hey the Messiah is coming.
Okay? And in the Arabian desert, there's
a man who believes he's the Messiah. His
name is Muhammad. Okay.
All right. Keep on reading.
>> Jews were expelled from Jer Jerusalem
and were not allowed to settle within
the three mile radius. A general mass
massacre of the Jewish population
ensued. The massacre devastated the
Jewish communities of the Gal Galilea
and Jer Jer Jerusalem. Only those Jews
who could flee to the mountains of Egypt
are said to have been spared.
>> Okay. So this is Wikipedia. Okay. All
right. So the first thing that
Muhammad's going to do is announce the
constitution of Medina, which is say
that I'm the prophet. I am the Messiah.
But what I promise you is religious
openness and tolerance. It doesn't
matter if you're Jew. It doesn't matter
if you're Christian. It doesn't matter
if you're Arab. You can practice
whatever religion you want. It's and
it's called the constitution of Medina.
Okay? That's a promise that Muhammad
makes to all his followers.
Okay? And we know this from the Quran.
So, we're going to read the Quran
together, which the holy book of the
Muslims. And what we'll see is that
Muhammad is clearly promising
tolerance for all religious uh factions.
Doesn't matter what religion you are,
you're you're allowed to practice
whatever you want. Okay. So, Alan, can
you read please?
>> Oh, people of the book, why do you argue
about Abraham when the Torah and the
Gospel were not revealed until after
him? Why you not reason? Here you are.
You argue about things you know. But why
do you argue about things you know, do
you do not know? A knows, Allah knows,
and you do not know. Abraham was neither
a Jew nor a Christian but he was a
monotheist a Muslim and he was not of
the polytheist. The people mo most
deserving of Abraham are those who
follow him and these prophet and those
who believe Allah is the guardian of the
believers.
>> Okay. So the legend is that Muhammad
when he was 40 he went into the desert
and in the desert he was meditating and
he had a revelation an angel Gabriel
visited him and spoke the truth of the
universe. The Quran is just a writing
down of all these revelations. Okay. And
one major revelation is Gabriel Gabriel
tells to tells Muhammad you're all
children of God. You're all descendants
of Abraham.
Therefore, why are you guys fighting?
You guys should be working together.
Okay?
All these differences don't matter.
What's important is for you all to
remember that you all believe in the one
true God. That's what matters. And um
these differences
don't really matter. Okay. Okay. Keep on
reading.
>> Yeah. They dis disbelieve with who those
who say Allah is the Messiah, the son of
Mary. But the Messiah himself said, "Oh
children of Israel, worship Allah, my
Lord and your Lord. Whoever has as sides
others with Allah. Allah has forbidden
him paradise and his dwelling is the
fire. The rondors have no saviors."
>> Okay, so this is really important. What
the Quran is saying is this Jesus is not
God. God is God. God is Allah. Jesus is
a messenger. Okay. And the messenger
himself Jesus himself said worship God.
Don't worship me. Okay. So this is a
netorian decision, right? Okay. Jesus is
human. In heaven he's divine but on
earth he's human. Okay. Keep on going.
They disbelieve those who say Allah is a
third of three. But there is no dainty
act except the one God. If they do not
refrain from what they say, a painful
torment will be before those among them
who disbelieve.
>> Okay, so this is saying that the Holy
Trinity is sacrilege. It's blessing. It
makes no sense, man. God is God. God
isn't one of three. Okay. God is just
God. Keep on going. Why they not repent
to Allah as ask forgiveness? Allah is
forgiving and merciful. The Messiah son
of Mary was only a m messenger before
whom other messengers had passed away
and his mother was a woman of truth.
They both used to eat food. Note how we
make clear the re revelation to them
that note how delude they are. Okay. To
say that Mary is divine. You say that
Jesus is divine. It's all superstitious.
They're all just messengers of the one
true God like Moses and like uh like
Moses before him. Okay. And now like
Muhammad today. Okay, Moses, Jesus, and
Muhammad are all messages of God. Jesus
was the penultimate and Muhammad is the
last. Okay, the final messenger of God.
All right, keep on keep with him are the
keys of the unseen. None knows them
except he and he knows everything on
land and in the sea. Not a leaf falls,
but he knows it. And there is not a
single grain in the darkness of earth,
nor is there anything wet or dry, but is
in a clear record.
It is he who takes you by night, and he
knows what you earn by day. Then he
raises you up in it until a fixed them
term is fulfilled. Then to him is your
return. Then he will inform you of what
you used to do. He is a conqueror over
his servant and he send guardians over
you until when death overtakes one of
you our envoys take him away and they
never fail. Then they are brought back
to Allah the true master. Unquestionably
he is the judgment and he is the swift
swift test of reck reckers.
>> This is establishing the monad right as
god. The monad is the universe. The
monad is everything. It's divine. Okay,
stop saying Jesus is God. That makes no
sense.
All right. Okay. So, as we discussed,
now the Iranian desert, it's energized.
People are energetic [clears throat]
because people's thirst for religious
liberation. Okay. The Christians, the
Jews all unite behind Muhammad. And very
quickly, they're able to once he's able
to unite the Arabs. Okay. They're now
really quickly able to expand outwards.
They retake Jerusalem.
and they conquer the Persian Empire very
very quickly because both of these
empires the bisonines and the assassins
are exhausted. The main advantage of the
bisines is they have still have console
which is impossible to conquer. Okay. So
consoles like um is safe but every falls
to the Arabs.
Okay. And as you can see how fast their
conquest is and this is only about 100
years. Okay. They're able to basically
conquer most of the Roman Empire. They
take Spain, they take Northern Africa,
they conquer Persia. Okay, it's a really
rapid conquest because at this point in
history, people are just sick of empires
and they're looking for religious
liberation.
Okay? And over time, but over time as
Muhammad dies, the Muslims will fight
amongst themselves and they will
establish different um empires called
caliphats and they will break up as
well. Okay? And this will give time for
the basicines to
um reestablish themselves and then
Western Europe will become more and more
powerful.
Now the Arabs will establish something
called the Islamic Golden Age. And this
marks a time of tremendous peace and
prosperity for the world because the
Muslims are able to establish trade
networks throughout the world. Okay?
Why? Well, because when you do trade,
the biggest problem is one of trust,
right? How can I trust you to take my
money to somewhere else? But if you're a
Muslim, you are you must swear to Allah.
Okay? So religion requires you to be
trustworthy and that allows Muslims to
work together and establish trade routes
throughout the world. But you can't
really trust someone who's not Muslim,
but you trust someone who is Muslim.
Okay? So these Muslims go all around the
world and including into China and as
such
um the Islamic Empire is able to
establish trade throughout the world
which brings tremendous prosperity to
most of the world. Okay.
Um as and as you can I'm not sure you
don't understand Islam but Islam is a
beautiful simple religion that builds
trust and community. Uh this is Mecca
and this is the Haj where
Muslims come from all the world and they
circle around the kebab the the cube.
Okay.
Um so Islam consider itself as the
ultimate religion because it improves on
both Judaism and Christianity. Okay.
Christians believe they are improving on
Judaism. Islams Muslims believe they're
an improvement on Christians and Jews as
well.
Okay. Now let's talk about the Western
Empire. Okay. Because that's where our
focus will be for the next um for for
the rest of semester. 476
the GS destroy Rome. Why? Because
because the power now is being shifted
from the empire to Catholic Church.
Okay. So the empire doesn't really have
have that much power.
So what happens is that it recruits
mercenaries to fight for them but it
can't really pay the mercenaries. So the
mercenaries in response go and sack
Rome. Okay. By this time in history Rome
is no longer a power. It doesn't it
doesn't really matter anymore. [snorts]
Augustine who is the main architect of
the Catholic Church. Okay. He takes
Paul's ideas and systemize it. He
teaches us in the city of God that
Catholic Church is out of history. It is
beyond history. It is divine. Okay? So
the kings can fight over the land, but
it's the church who will decide who goes
to heaven and who burns in hell. And
that's the power of the church. One
thing to remember about um Europe is
like there are lots of geographic
barriers which allows for diversity
within Europe. Okay, that's why Europe
has so many countries because it
historically it's been very hard to
unify Europe because of the geography
and this allows for tremendous diversity
and it creates a lot of conflict as well
which drives innovation. Okay, so this
is when the when the Roman Empire falls
in in the west uh there are lots of
different groups fighting for remains.
Now what's really important to
understand about history is when we say
the Roman Empire rises and it falls.
This is our understanding of them. Okay.
But from their perspective, the empire
never fell because these warlords think
that I'm the empire now. Okay? And so
what's going to happen is that they're
going to be compete for the legacy of
Rome.
And eventually this leads to the rise of
a new power
um the Franks. Okay, so the Franks are
expanding throughout Europe and they see
themselves as the here to the Roman
Empire. But how do you prove that you
are here to Roman Empire? How do you
legitimize yourself? Well, you need to
get the Catholic Church on your side.
Right?
So in about 800 Charlemagne who is the
king of Franks, he is crowned Holy Roman
Emperor by the Pope. Okay. And from now
on it is the Catholic Church, the Pope
who decides who will be the Holy Roman
Emperor. There's a negoti negotiating
going on but on public for the public
the Holy Roman Empire is always anointed
by God.
Okay, this is Charlemagne and uh today
he is buried in the Aken Cathedral.
Okay, one of the most beautiful
buildings in the world. His body is
still there. Okay, the king cathedral
and this this is what it looks like
inside.
Okay, now the Catholic Church because of
this power is now able to anoint the
Holy Roman Empire. it becomes wealthy.
Okay. Okay. So, can you read this Ellen
from the Bible?
>> Yeah. Then Jesus said to his disciples,
"Assuredly I said to you that it is hard
for a rich man to enter the kingdom of
heaven. And again, I say to you, it is
easier for a camel to go through the eye
of a needle than for a rich man to enter
the kingdom of God." So, as I keep on
telling you, Jesus himself was very
anti-rich. Okay? He believed that the
rich people because they were too
focused on material acquisitions could
never go into heaven. Okay. But the
paradox is that
the Catholic Church becomes extremely
wealthy. Okay. If you go to the Vatican,
you can still go go back and you visit
St. Pet Basilica. It is one of the most
beautiful buildings in the world. It's
extremely wealthy. Inside, guys, it's
all gold. Okay. All right. Right. So the
Vatican is has been historically the
wealthiest organization in the world
and it was able to do this because
um Western Europe started to become very
wealthy over time. Okay. So from about
a,000 to about 1300 the population of
Europe doubles because of technology
innovation because the climate is
warming allowing for agriculture
um because of the rise of cities and
because Europe is trading with everyone.
Okay. So at this time uh Europe is
becoming more more wealthy which makes
the Catholic Church really really
wealthy. Okay. These are different urban
centers of um Europe at this time and
they engage mainly in trade.
Okay. So, the church becomes a much more
powerful idea than the empire. Okay.
Why? Well, with an empire, it's the
emperor who's in charge, right? But the
emperor is still a human being and
therefore he can change his mind and he
doesn't really know what what he's
doing. But in the church, the person in
charge is God who is perfect, immunable,
and eternal. Okay? So, this is the
ultimate authority, the church. Second
is what is the mandate? Well, an empire
demands
that you work hard, your labor, but the
church demands your soul, your
obedience.
Okay? Therefore, the church is able to
extract more wealth from you. The last
thing is, okay, let's say you don't obey
the empire. What's the wor worst thing
that can happen to you? Well, the empire
puts you to death. Okay, not a big deal.
But the church, what it can do is send
you in hell for all of eternity. Okay,
that's why the the Catholic Church
becomes the most powerful organization
ever in human history and it's still
true today.
[snorts]
All right. So, what makes the um
Catholic Church so powerful? What
becomes a divine bureaucracy? Okay. Um
and what it does is establish a very
strict hierarchy.
So the idea of the church is that God is
distant and God demands your obedience.
Right? So remember Augustine, city of
God, remember Paul, right? So um one
thing is that when you go to church, the
priest doesn't speak in your language,
the vernacular, it speaks in Latin. And
you don't really understand the
language. Okay? You're not allowed to
read the Bible because at this time most
people are illiterate. Um the Holy
Trinity makes no sense. But again,
you're not asked to debate it. You're
not asked to question it. You're just
you just have to memorize it. Um there
are lots of rituals
to the Catholic Church. Some of these
rituals are just really weird. So for
the example of the Eucharist where you
believe that you're actually eating the
body and blood of Jesus through the idea
of sub transubst
trans substitation okay um the church is
powerful because it can determine who
goes to heaven and hell and for how how
long and ultimately if you don't if you
are a king you don't obey the church the
pope can excommunicate you which which
is say I remove I remove you from the
Christian community and therefore any
other king can come and kill you and
it'll be good in the eyes of God. Okay,
does that make sense? So this is how why
the church is so powerful but also
explain helps us explain why the church
is so corrupt as well. They have too
much power
and ultimately they will use this power
in order to enrich themselves. Okay,
remember the Catholic church people who
control the Catholic Church are
descendants of the Roman nobility. Okay.
They will use Catholic Church to en
enrich themselves. They say something
called indulgences. And the idea is
let's say you're a rich person and you
did a lot of bad things and now you're
afraid you you'll burn in hell, right?
Well, Jesus will say, "Too bad." But the
Catholic Church says, "Give us a lot of
money and we'll give you an indulgence."
Okay? Basically, you know, a uh ticket
to purgatory. All right? And so, as you
can see, there's a lot of corruption
going on. something called simony where
you can buy and sell positions in
Catholic church very similar to the
imperial bureaucracy of China right uh
they're selling holy relics
priests are not really divine they get
married uh they sell their positions to
nobles
um and the kings are the ones who can
appoint leaders of the church as well
okay so there's this negotiation going
on between the Catholic church and the
kings as well
um the parish the parishioners no matter
how poor they are they're forced to pay
a tax. They they pay a tax to the
Catholic Church and not to the king.
Okay? As you can imagine, the king is
not really happy about about this
because a third of his land, most of his
tax revenue, it's being taken over by
the Catholic Church. So that's why a lot
of kings will eventually start to rebel
against the Catholic Church. Okay? Um
the church controls one-third of all
land in Europe tax-free.
Okay? And this leads to feudalism.
All right.
Um, so at the same time though, even
though the Catholic Church is so
powerful in Europe, it still has a
legitimacy problem. Okay? Meaning like
how does it prove that it is truly
divine?
Well, you have some certain problems.
The first problem is the Muslims occupy
the Holy Land. Okay? If you are truly if
you truly represent God, why is
Jerusalem in the hands of the Muslims?
Okay. Also, Spain is part of Europe, but
Muslim Spain is actually much more
wealthy and innovative than the rest of
Europe.
Um, 1054, the Eastern Orthodox Church
led by the Byzantines break with
the Catholic Church. Okay? Because both
want want to be the ultimate center of
the world. But the Bison says that we're
the center and the Romans say, "No,
we're the center." Okay? Um
and there's corruption going on. Okay,
everyone says corruption, but there's
also lots of religious leaders who are
rebelling against Catholic Church
because they want to unleash a divine
spark. Okay, so there's all this legitim
legitimacy problems going on.
And so there are different solutions.
Okay, one solution the Catholic Church
does is that it persecutes Jews.
Okay. So the Catholic Church allows Jews
to exist just so that the Catholic
Church can scapegoat
the Jews. And throughout this time, as
you can see, Jews are being persecuted
mainly by being forced out of their
homes where they lived for hundreds of
years. Okay? And a lot of them are
forced to go east into the Muslim Empire
and to go to Spain. Okay?
But over time there's being expelled
from these regions.
Um this is another map that shows the
persecution of the Jews. As as you can
see they're forced to go uh east. Okay.
And often there are lots of massacres as
well. Okay. So the black spots, okay,
the skull spots are areas in which they
were massacred. they were blamed for
certain crimes. Okay.
All right. Um
so this is a map that shows the pil the
pilgrimages of Christians into the holy
land. Okay. And again, it's a source of
embarrassment for the Christians that
their holy land is occupied by Muslims
and they have to pay a tax with Muslims
and they go into the holy land.
Um, right now the Holy Land, Jerusalem
is being controlled by the Sojic Turks,
okay? The Ottoman Empire.
All right? And that's why Pope Orin the
second will eventually call for the
crusades to liberate the holy land from
the Muslims. Okay. So can you read
please? All who die by the way, whether
by land or by sea, or in battle against
a penguins, shall have immediate
remission of sins. Or what a disgrace if
such a despise and base raised, which
worship demons should conquer a people
which has the face of only potent god
and is made glorious with the name of
Christ.
>> Okay.
Let those who have been accustomed
unjustly to wage private warfare against
the faithful now go against the infidels
and end with victory this war which
should have been begun long ago. Let
those who for a long time have been
robbers now become knights. Let those
who have been fighting against the
brothers and relevates now fight in a
proper way against the barbarians. that
those who have been serving as
mercenaries for small pay now obtain the
eternal reward.
>> Okay, so this is this is Pope Orb saying
the crusades. It's to go and fight the
demons. And if you fight a demon, it
doesn't matter who you are. You could be
poor, you could be rich, you could be a
sinful person, you could be a nobody,
but now it's just your opportunity to go
to heaven. Okay? The like when you go to
fight the demons, you will all be
guaranteed access to heaven. no matter
who you are, no matter what you did.
And so, uh, a lot of people go and join
the crusades for lots of different
reasons, especially those who've
committed crimes before. Okay? So, guess
what? A lot of people join the crusades
are criminals because here's your
opportunity to uh get good with the
church. Okay?
That's why we see a lot of abuse during
the crusades. Okay? So, as you can see,
lots of people are now joining the
crusades in order to liberate the Holy
Land
and eventually they succeed. Okay? Even
though a lot of criminals,
um they're still very good fighters
because they have religious devotion.
Okay? They're very energetic.
And unfortunately,
um they're too energetic. So they have
tendency to massacre people when they
succeed because they literally see the
Muslims
and the Jews as demons. That's what the
pope taught them.
Um one organization that developed
during the crusades is called the
Knights Templars. Okay, this is very
important. We'll be discussing Knights
Templars later on. Okay, but the Knights
Templars is really the first
multinational bank because these
pilgrims are going to holy land and they
need to bring money with them to fund
the journey. But if they take a lot of
money with them, then they'll get
robbed, right? So what they'll do is
they'll give the money to nice templars
and then when they get to Jerusalem, the
nice templars will give the money back
to them. Okay? So they're a bank
basically and then they can use this
money to start investing throughout of
Europe and so they become a very wealthy
organization.
The problem is that because in Jerusalem
and away from the authority of Catholic
Church, they start to embrace new ideas.
They start to discover the true nature
of Jesus from the Muslims and from other
Christians in that area. And so the
church thinks that they become more
corrupt over time. And that's why
their leader Jack De Mole, he is burnt
at the stake. And in 1307, the
organization is banned by the Catholic
Church. But a lot of the survivors they
will go over to other places and they
will and they will form the basis of a
secret society we call the Freemasons.
Okay. So we'll discuss the Freemasons
later on.
Okay. There's also something called the
albborene
crusade. So there are still individuals
who believe in the divine spark. Okay.
And these people call are called
cathars. And the church sees him as a
threat and that's why they launch a
crusade against these caththers. Okay.
So can you can you read Alan?
Seaman and many of his soldiers made
determined effort to convert the Cather
perfect but failed.
>> Okay. So again the Catholic Church is if
you disagree with us it doesn't mean
you're a heretic. It just means you're
stupid. So our so we first want to
educate you in what is right. Okay. The
Cathers believed that no, the divine
spark is in me. I know the truth for
myself. You can never convince me. Okay,
keep keep on going. Ultimately, only
three women recented. The 140 who
refused were burned at the stake. Some
entered the flames voluntarily, not
awaiting their executioners.
>> So if you believe in the divine spark,
okay, you believe you've discovered
truth. You're not afraid of death. So
you so the the Catholics are saying like
if you don't we can't we'll burn you at
the stake. The Catholics are like good
keep on going.
>> In August the crusade proceeded to
besiege the stronghold of Teras despite
sales sies from period rocker de decap
decaparate. The siege wears solid. The
occupants of Terminal suffered from a
shortage of water and ro Roman Real
Duris agreed to a temporary truce. The
Cathers were briefly relieved by an
intense rainstorm and so Reman refused
to surrender. Ultimately, the defenders
were not able to break the siege and on
22 November the Cathers managed to
abandon the city and escape. By the time
operations resumes in uh 1002 1,211,
the actions of honored armory and seaman
de Montford had alignate alienated
several important lords including
Raymond D. Tollos who has been
excommunicated again.
>> Okay. So as you can see what's really
important to understand is the crusade
against cathars is not just a religious
crusade. It's also one of geopolitics
where the local lords resent the power
of the Catholic church and so they
support the caththers. Okay. All right.
So, and this is going to happen
throughout Europe. So, um um the
response of the church is to establish a
new society led by Francis of Aisi
called the Dominicans. Okay. The
Dominicans which goes which goes and and
basically tries to figure out who the
Caththers are. Okay. by interrogating
everyone.
All right? And this leads to of course
the equition.
Okay?
Um
and so the idea is that if you disagree
with church orthodoxy, they will figure
it out. And if you refuse to recant, if
you refuse to obey, they will burn you
at the stake. Okay? So at this time in
history because of the inquisition,
because of the power of the Catholic
Church, Western Europe is one of the
least innovative places in the world.
Okay?
All right.
And at first this is fine, but
eventually
um bad things start to happen in Europe.
Okay? So the little the little ice age
begins, then you have the great famine,
then you have more wars, then you have
benetry. Okay? And then of course you
have the black death. So if the Catholic
Church represents the will of God and
all this is happening
then is God really happy with the
Catholic Church, right?
So this is a black death which kills
about a third of the European
population. And people because they're
religious, they think that this is the
will of God. It's because the Catholic
Church, it's corrupt. It's evil. It's
stagnant. That's why God is punishing
us. Okay.
Um and this will lead to conflict within
Europe where the Catholic Church is
actually broken into different parts as
well. Okay. So there are some who
believe that uh Rome is the true center
center of the Catholic Church and there
are other people who believe that Ammon
okay is the true center of the Catholic
church and this creates even more
legitimacy problems with the Catholic
Church.
All right and then you have individuals
who will emerge to challenge the
orthodoxy of the Catholic Church. Okay.
So this is this is Freight Dosina. We
don't read [snorts]
uh John White is a British person who
was um he didn't he was not punished
when he was alive but afterwards after
he died they decided he was a heretic.
So what they did was they dug up his
body and then burned him up the stake to
make sure he he burned in hell. Okay.
Uh Jen Hus will lead a revolution. Okay.
And this is called the Husk wars.
And none none succeed. But then another
man will emerge called Martin Luther who
will eventually lead a successful
revolution against Catholic Church. And
this is called Protestantism.
Protestatismism. Okay. And we'll discuss
Martin Luther next class. Next class.
Next class we will discuss the rise of
capitalism. All right. Any questions
guys? Yes.
Like there's a case of my mother friend
telling me that she uh her her her
husband has a uh severe cancer and they
tr they try to pray to the Catholic
church and like later the cancer just
disappears and they said it is miracle
by the c Catholic church and they all
believe in the cath catholic church. Can
it explain the miracle like is there
really really miracle there?
>> Okay. Yeah. Okay, back to your question.
Okay, so this is what we call the
placebo effect.
Okay, the placebo effect is basically
um
you feel really sick
and you're like, "Doctor, doctor, I'm
really sick. I'm going to die. Is there
any medicine that that can save me?" And
I'm a doctor and I I don't want to say
there is no medicine. Uh, so I say,
"Okay, well here here's some here here's
here's a medicine. Okay, it might help
you, but this but this medicine does
nothing. You take this medicine and then
you feel better. You you get better."
And this happens a lot. Okay, it's
called it's called the placebo effect.
So why does this happen? It happens
because if you if you understand that
mind leads to matter
then
your reality is shaped by your
perception your belief. Okay. So if you
believe that this medicine
can improve your body then it will have
effects. Okay. The question though is
how much do you really believe in this
medicine?
Okay. So you can argue that cancer it's
really a question of loss of faith.
What is cancer? Cancer is a splitting of
cells, right? So why is your body
literally falling apart? It's because
you've stopped believing in yourself.
You've stopped believing in the purpose
of life. You've stopped believing that
you have relevance in the world.
Okay. So, when you say, "I want to cure
my cancer. I want to cure my cancer."
What you're really saying is, "I want to
find a new faith. I want to believe in
myself again. I want to reestablish my
relevance in the world." Okay? Does that
make sense? So, you have the desire.
Once you have the desire, then the cure
makes sense.
Okay? So,
>> so, so, so another way of saying this
is, okay, let's just say that you don't
feel well, right? Well,
if your parents make you go see a
psychiatrist,
you probably won't feel better. But if
you yourself want to get better and you
go see a psychiatrist, you'll probably
get better. Okay? So
why this person why he or she improved
his or her cancer is because
um of faith.
Okay? She won't get better.
So if you're able to orientate your mind
in a certain way, you're capable of
tremendous miracles. Another another
idea is that idea of meditation, right?
If you're able to control your thoughts,
if you're able to calm yourself down,
your body will heal a lot faster. Okay?
Does that make sense?
>> Right. Okay. Any more questions?
Okay. Great. So next class we will we'll
discuss capitalism.